y esta cosa está arriba en el cielo No
tengo idea de Qué es ha estado allí
estacionario Durante los últimos 35
minutos en el estado de montaña este
globo fue captado en cámara por
aficionados el pentágono sospecha que el
objeto Volador ha sido enviado por China
para vigilar las bases militares
cruciales ubicadas en el área los
expertos dicen que es la primera vez que
un globo espía flota durante tanto
tiempo en el espacio aéreo
estadounidense
han hecho esto antes pero no es común y
se cree que el globo de vigilancia
merodea más tiempo que los globos de
vigilancia anteriores que los chinos han
enviados
puede ser que ESPN más tiempo en ciertos
lugares para vigilar áreas donde los
chinos creen que hay instalaciones
militares de Estados Unidos y pueden
obtener imágenes de mayor resolución
los servicios de inteligencia
estadounidense han estado monitoreando
de cerca la trayectoria del globo pero
el objeto no ha sido derribado por temor
a causar daños en tierra las reacciones
de los políticos estadounidenses e
incluso de las fuerzas armadas de Canadá
inundaron en internet se detectó un
globo de vigilancia a gran altitud y
norat está rastreando activamente sus
movimientos los canadienses están a
salvo y Canadá está tomando medidas para
garantizar la seguridad de su espacio
aéreo Washington ha transmitido la
gravedad del incidente Beijing el
Ministerio de relaciones exteriores de
China ha respondido diciendo que está
verificando la situación
china es un país responsable y siempre
ha respetado las leyes internacionales y
no tiene intención de violar el
territorio y espacio aéreo de ningún
país soberano en cuanto al globo lo
estamos investigando y Esperamos que
ambos lados puedan manejar esto juntos
con calma la visita inesperada del globo
se produce solo unos días antes que el
secretario blinken viaje a Beijing para
aliviar las tensiones respecto a Taiwán
pero si el globo fuera realmente chino
es posible que la reunión no transcurra
en los mejores términos